the road to success is paved with
enormous screw-ups
and earth's mightiest heroes have had
their share of bad luck how bad you may
well ask
well let's take a gander beware possible
spoilers ahead
if marvel studios ever decides to draw
on seriously the dumbest stories in its
history
even with the clunky captain america
costume and the shoehorned cap thor iron
man fight scene
2012's avengers is still better than the
nightmare that was avengers number one
brought together by the chicanery of
loki the original avengers
consisted of iron man thor ant-man and
the wasp banding together to take down
the hulk
tony zama looked like a gold-plated iron
lung on legs thor
still waffling between his personas as a
god of thunder and surgeon donald blake
keeps his identity a secret by loudly
announcing what he's doing every time he
transforms into the asgardian deity the
hulk runs from battle at one point and
pretty immediately disguises himself as
a super strong juggling clown robot
in a travelling circus then there's
ant-man and the wasp ant-man berates
wasp for being a woman
when he and janet arrive at their first
avengers meeting they stand on a
projector to make themselves big enough
to talk to instead of just growing to
person's size
they try to capture hulk by having ants
dig a hole under him and are defeated
when hulk blows a fireplace bellows at
them
captain america didn't join the avengers
until four issues into their adventures
how did steve rogers get to the party it
was a little problematic
thor ant-man wasp and iron man were
pitted against golden age staple neymar
the submariner
neymar escapes the tussle and makes his
way to the north sea
where he finds a group of
uncomprehending eskimos worshiping a
petrified figure as mighty lord of the
frozen ice
namor having been gifted with the
strength of a typhoon and intense
crabbiness
breaks apart the ice and sends a frozen
figure floating into warmer waters where
his frigid shell melts around him
you've been asleep cap for almost 70
years
the frozen figure captain america the
avengers pass on their submarine and
they make captain america
prove that he's captain america by
having an all-out brawl with him while
still inside the submarine
ignoring the fact that they're in a
pressurized tube surrounded by tons of
water
they punch dive and meow near their way
to clarity until wasp
shuts the whole thing down by standing
in front of cap and basically daring him
to hit a girl
the year was 1988 and frankly it was
time for superheroes to do something
about rock and roll the west coast
avengers within spitting distance of
having their book cancelled
found themselves drawn into the path of
the defiler a suburban dad's idea of a
threatening rock star
while he may have appeared to be an
innocent skull adorned behemoth of
glamrock fronting a band called
corruption of innocence
he was secretly up to no good the filer
was an interventional demon
using the seductive power of loud music
to draw in america's youth
throwing them into portals and draining
them of their good vibrations
luckily for all of those easily
manipulated kids the only thing more
powerful than the nebulously described
powers of a heavily tasseled devil bad
guy
is ant-man he saves the day using a
giant chainsaw a giant skateboard
a giant catcher's mitt and a giant
amount of faith in the idea that readers
would be into this
the filer gets knocked into one of his
own portals and that's the last we ever
heard from him
thanos was a big jerk but darned if that
didn't stop the avengers from recruiting
the mad titan's brother eras to the team
better known by his superhero moniker
star fox he was a late in the game
addition to earth's mightiest heroes
having the more well-meaning sibling of
an unbeatable space god on your side
seems like a good idea on paper can you
imagine the sheer power he probably
brought to the fight but star fox in
addition to the usual powers of super
strength
flight and so on possesses the ability
to super womanize
he stimulates the pleasure centers in
other beings brains making them
susceptible to star foxerae
he was even put on trial for sexual
assault in the mid-2000s
in the 1990s comic book companies were
in hot water
dc had burst the collector's market with
the death of superman and marvel was on
the verge of bankruptcy
so they teamed up and dc versus marvel
was born
it was a four-issue series of books in
which the two companies
represented by two cosmic gods send
their respective champions into battle
against one another the ensuing melees
saw members of the avengers getting
slapped around something fierce by their
dc opponents
hulk took a beat down from superman
captain america like all who faced
gotham's dark knight
got hit with a batarang and fell down
thor did alright managing to stop shazam
then still called captain marvel by
preventing his magic lightning from
transforming him into a super self
but it was a victory that was dampened
slightly by the fact that it was 1996
and we were still
23 years away from zachary levi making
most people care who shazam was
in the aftermath of dc vs marvel comics
the two gods representing the companies
got together
and created an all-new comic book
universe the amalgam universe
all of the two companies best-selling
characters saw themselves merged into
half marvel half dc hybrid versions of
themselves
the results were hit to miss and
generally more than a little slanted in
one character's direction
there was super soldier the captain
america superman hybrid that answered
the question
what if superman had all of his powers
and also a shield there was dark claw a
batman wolverine combo
that combined wolverine's powers with
batman's costume doctor strange and dr
fate became dr strange fate
he was a magic guy in essence the two
biggest comic book publishers in the
world did what sid from toy story did to
his dolls in 2000
marvel launched its ultimate line a
modern rebooting of all its classic
characters in a parallel universe
at its best we got ultimate spider-man a
series of solid writing
and exciting reimaginings of the heroes
and villains that fans had loved for
decades
at its worst there was ultimatum
ultimatum was a crossover event
branching from mark miller's perpetually
gritty reboot of the avengers the
ultimate
it was written by jeff loeb the mind
behind classics like batman the long
halloween and superman for all seasons
the series went off the rails the wasp's
intestines get eaten out of her torso
on panel by the blob hank pym bites the
head off the offending eater
pym later explodes doctor strange's head
blows up and thor martyrs himself
also manhattan drowns it's grim
the mid 90s were a tough time for marvel
sales were plummeting
and story lines had become too
convoluted for casual readers to keep
pace
the publisher needed to shake things up
they needed something fresh
instead of doing that marvel handed his
comics to rob liefeld and hoped it fixed
everything
in late 1996 marvel launched heroes
reborn
spearheaded by leifeld and jim lee it
took the avengers along with a few other
marvel a-listers
and put them in a slightly different
universe with slightly different origin
stories the event also included some
redesigns of the characters that
sidestepped typical human anatomy
nobody walked away unscathed but poor
captain america got the worst of it his
redesign left readers with an illusion
of machismo fueled body horror destined
for meme hood
given his charismatic movie persona it's
possible you've forgotten that tony
stark has had some rough moments
the one at the dude's wardrobe was a
mess take the mark 1
immortalized in 2008's iron man sword of
a ned kelly mech suit the outfit first
appeared in comics and tales of suspense
issue 39 back in 1963.
it wasn't great it got the job done
protecting tony and keeping his heart
going
but some of its other features were
objectively less super
for example it had suction cups on the
hands so tony could attach to the
ceiling
not bad luckily by the mark ii star had
improved on his original design
significantly by um
painting it gold it was slow going at
first tony's suit seemed to follow the
adam west utility belt tradition
of doing whatever specific ridiculous
thing needed doing he spent a good time
getting around on roller skates for one
he built a scuba suit that shot ink like
a squid
and of course there was a cartoonishly
proportioned whitey one armor
[Music]
imagine you've been invited to hang out
at a professional level with a super
soldier
a god a billionaire and a hulk you can
talk to ants
and shrink this friends is the burden on
ant-man hank pym has a long and sordid
history of decidedly and heroic behavior
back in mark miller's ultimate's run an
argument ended with hank hitting his
wife
dousing her in bug spray and setting his
ants on her before that there was
avengers issue 213
where pym now calling himself
yellowjacket backhanded the wasp when
she pointed out that he was acting crazy
he eventually quit the avengers over it
and now scott lang cosplays as him
as your mother
i didn't mean to lose you too
scarlet witch has had a doozy of a time
trying to start a family her most well
publicized misadventure into domesticity
came with 2005's house of m event in
which she tried to create her own kids
whole cloth
by reconstructing the fabric of reality
weirdly that wasn't the most surreal
example
in the 80s wonder maximoff tried to
create a pair of kids with magic
with her as a mother and vision as the
father what she got ended up being an
unholy and overly complex manifestation
of shards of a demon's soul then the
super villain master pandemonium got his
hands on them
or rather they got on his hands long
story short master pandemonium is a
demonic antagonist with the power to
turn his arms into demons
the minute he got within reach of
wanda's kids he grafted them onto the
ends of his elbows and he had baby arms
yes one of the avengers foes once fought
the team with babies for arms
incidentally versions of wonders kids
eventually went on to join the young
avengers
with the meteoric rise of the mcu over
the last decade the casual viewer might
ask themselves
why didn't anyone try to make marvel
movies sooner a few filmmakers did
and they were awful captain america had
some cereals in the 1940s and those have
sort of a nostalgic charm
after that it's tough to find an avenger
with a worthwhile movie outing there was
the 1977 spider-man
starring a man in pajamas and enormous
web shooters desperately scurrying up
buildings
thor appears in 1988's the incredible
hulk returns
the tv movie continuation of the
incredible hulk tv series with a thor
adorned in fur
there's also the movie length pilot for
a doctor strange series starring a young
jessica walter
aka lucille bluth as morgan le faye and
peter hooton as a good doctor
and who could forget that david
hasselhoff played nick fury a mere 10
years before sam jackson took on the
role
a lot of people probably i always heard
living wells the best revenge
it's not just every single marvel
character that's searching for
redemption
it's marvel itself check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about
marvel are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one